feminine energy is not always sweet and
soft that's what's been taught in a very
patriarchal masculine dominant world
what I call the mother Mary facet that's
the softness that feminine has been more
accepted in our Collective for a really
long time but she is not the only one so
collie is an energy that literally when
you call on colie she comes in with her
sword and she is traditionally depicted
as having a sword in her hand and she
has a decapitated head of a demon in her
other hand she slays the demons meaning
all demons of your ego she destroys
everything in your life that's not meant
to be there but do you see how different
that is so what you're saying is I walk
into physical spaces and I'm holding
more of a sexual maybe even Isis energy
there are so many facets to the feminine
we can always go into the animal kingdom
you know and the the example that I love
to give of that facet of the feminine is
a lioness with her cup if a lioness has
her cup you're not going to play games
with her try and touch her cub and see
what she does to you that's a feminine
energy